have you made up your mind no matter how
much thinking you do there's only one
option you'd be better off just
listening to me
[Music]
hmm could that rumor cat be somewhere
nearby
could that rumored cat be somewhere
nearby
indeed hi guys I'm Lucy and I'm tomorrow
and if you've been on the GameSpot
YouTube channel looking for persona 5
you'll have found a bunch of footage in
Japanese but look at this English it's
been localized
finally we have some captured right here
so we get a first look at it oh man
look how pretty look at it it's so
pretty so persona 4 we see you in a
small town you were introduced I guess
as this kid who moved from the big city
no one really knew a lot about you it's
pretty much very similar in persona 5
except you're in a big struggle yo but
you have a rumored bad past oh yeah and
this guy seems to be very cold to you
who is this this is oh this is so Jiro
and he basically is Dojima who was your
caretaker I guess in persona 4 he's not
exactly thrilled that you're there he
owns a cafe the minute he's quite
annoyed cuz he came home late yeah
you've been up to no good
mmm technically I hadn't but yeah so
everyone is kind of very distrusting of
you they think you have a kind of
criminal past but here we have here we
can see are you kind of conversing with
your confidence yeah those are the
replacements for like social links or
other people in war verb an upgrade yeah
so these are people you spend your time
with to build their power outside of
dungeon-crawling yeah so we have on here
not an not even English in me once to
say an but it's lady on and the guy over
there is real G yeah he's basically like
a meld of Yosuke and kanji yeah
and we see them here entering kind of
the this is the through the TV bit but
not really cuz they're going into the
app it's an application they have on the
phone now to get them where they need to
be is it like you - it's in my iTunes
I don't a screen TV yeah it's just there
that's how it works and they're kind of
still figuring it out so they don't
completely know the rules of it so as
you can see on has mystery
we been sucked into it and they're not
quite sure how it happened yeah Morgana
has kind of some idea the cat has some
idea of what's going on but eat me like
how's amnesia so can't really joke
amnesia cat um so these are your kind of
confidence this is very near the
beginning of the game we should say this
is maybe like two hours in yeah and
you're sort of building up your pals to
go in we're not gonna spoil too much of
the story here because you know if you
if you didn't get all the spoilers when
they came out in Japan last year you can
wait you wait a few more weeks it's fine
we're not gonna do it I'm not gonna
spoil it there's a safe zone so here in
the palace you kind of like a magic
incantation to get through you kind of
need like a name a location and the app
and it as it's what's happened with on
here is that she was sort of standing
near you while you went in and it pulled
her into yeah but otherwise you need
these kind of like special code words to
gain which is a surprising like it's
surprising the analog entry point for an
app yeah I've got these code words I've
set them now press the UP button and
let's go let's go in so this is cool
yeah so we're in a dungeon now um a mind
Palace I guess you're stealing can well
she just heart he's kind of a big bad of
this level and we're infiltrating at the
moment yeah which is kind of like they
want to give you a little more freedom
to get in and out of the castle so we
saw ramparts there early on the right
and that's kind of like a shortcut to
getting into some of the upper tier
levels but there's a reason for that and
that's they they're kind of encouraging
you to think about both sides of the
game a little more compared to persona
form persona 3 before it I mean look
here if you ran straight into that room
where all of those shadows are then it
wouldn't go well for you yeah that day
so they're giving you the opportunity to
sort of sneak around the outside um
you'll see in a minute as I look I mean
the guards the shadows kind of actually
like talk yeah now as opposed to just
kind of going forever because of course
shadows are born from people's hearts so
you might recognize this one actually
beguiling go you mean beguiling girl she
looks awfully like pixie yeah so we're
getting to see hold up which hole you
hold up which is new to persona 5 so in
for to get new personas you would get
these Arcana cards but now you can talk
to them and basically do a Bob Geldof
give us all your money
Wow um or you can ask for an item or you
can use this terrible line and get a
clap back here the island girl is not
pleased with your one-liners mmm I like
that they've gamified something which is
quite like uninvolved in the previous
game is almost like random drops and
also it gives you kind of like an
opportunity to interact with the
personas a little more yeah cuz
otherwise I mean something they would be
there and then they would go you know I
am that I and I'm gonna join you but now
you can actually talk to them a little
bit and into the mosques turn into
mosques so I don't know if the cards are
still actually gonna be there you can
still fuse personas to pass along stats
and abilities and everything but they
are in masks yeah and look at these guys
you should want to talk a little bit
about the cat
Morgana now cat of indeterminate gender
undetermined gender indeterminate gender
on unknown gender unknown gender yeah so
Morgana is serves the function of teddy
kind of basically Teddy meets Reese a
yeah so he she can it's never explicitly
said but they can give you directions
and battle kind of analyze but also they
have their favorites amongst the the
cast Morgana is looking for a waifu to
look at I mean like just look at the way
Morgana looks it on yeah horrible and
the cat also has a catapult love this
wordplay and you start each dungeon with
like a limited amount of ammo and you
obviously have to replenish that over
time because uh NATO had a gun yeah I
don't know she never
why not a bullet sir no um lovely AI
there so here this next bit is really
cool and it so basically what happens is
we're gonna get sprung on here and
instead of the shadows just having like
a 1-up it changes the way the battle
looks completely so it starts off with
you actually being surrounded by the
enemies as opposed to the other way
around and you are totally on the
defensive and you can't escape from the
battle because the enemies are sprung on
you yes I wants to start you off on the
back for in a more meaningful way like
you had that in the previous games where
the shadows would get up on you and hit
you and then maybe take a strike first
but this feels a little more like
challenging so you're surrounded and if
you really want to like get away from
battles you need to you know engage a
little bit at the very least that you
have to take one or two of them out to
give you an opening to escape so it's
just adding a little more strategy to
something that you know was quite
throwaway in the previous games yeah I
do actually really like that they've
done that because I mean certainly once
you go to the like grinding stage of
persona 4 which was admittedly a lot of
the SONA for yeah um you know you could
kind of just like roll through battles
and not really think about what you were
doing but now with the hold up stuff um
you can get items and money and new
personas and also when you're running
around it'll come up in a second you
kind of have a detection meter yeah so
you can't knee I mean that the game's
not outwardly saying sneaking around is
better yeah but there are incentives for
you to do that you see here we set off
some mobs yeah so if you want to be that
person who doesn't want to engage in
fights and you want to you know just get
to your objective without engaging too
many enemies it gives you a mechanical
way to do that instead of just trying to
fudge it by kind of like just running
around the edges it's like if you're
quiet you can get away with a little
more sneaking and uncover Slee it's
given you a sprint as well so if you
want to like really be over-the-top
about it and get away from enemies or
wherever it may be get around the
dungeon a bit quicker you can do that
too
so here um we forgot on she's in a bit
of a pickle we're not gonna really
go into the store stuff too much but the
guy in the in the robe and Crown and
pink speedos and not much else is
kimochi de and he is the not very
wholesome that guy no he's not but he's
the king of this palace and um on his
kind of you know pickle yeah and you
might know it as an on standing next to
him as well
bit weird yeah what's going on there
that's going on we won't say it's your
boy I recognize this guy yep so his name
is Belphegor yep from persona probably
three in four yep the King on his throne
you selfish laughs I love that they've
sort of gone above and beyond with the
localization injecting Abell personality
into the English version which is often
lost in in localizations or can be lost
in a lot of JRPG organisations yeah so
well we've got on and her persona is
called common what I what I like is that
they still have the very persona way of
naming the ability so like zero yes
electricity Aggie is fire and all that
stuff tear to heal all of that a lot
attack yeah so even those images give
like more life and person yeah a lot of
Flair in this game a lot of like
flourishes and it's kind of what we've
come to expect from atlas and the
persona series but they've really taken
it up to a new level with this one
everything from like the menu system
look quickly instead of having the
traditional box of attack whatever it
may be you know items which were used to
and has been a thing legacy in RPGs for
years and years now they've just given
it a little extra style and it kind of
surrounds you and gives you more screen
real estate to look right look at he
just pooped himself to he'll know why
are you gonna do poop Robbie on yourself
I mean this game this game and with that
food bombshell that's all we got time
for luckily we beat the guard captain
otherwise this would have been an
embarrassing video for more in persona 5
it's coming out in the West April Fool
and if you play it in English or you can
play it in Japanese they're giving you
both voice tracks which is quite cool
for more videos make sure to like this
one
subscribe to GameSpot on YouTube we'll
see you next time please be excited
please be excited you think there would
be a woman who could stand up King comes
schita
outside of school that guy's nothing but
a pathetic loser
you